how many hours a day is Jake
here on average day I'd say about three
three total hours in one day yeah yeah
is he in love is he your girlfriend a
video
game it's unbelievable a video game yeah
he's not playing it right now but I
guarantee he's thinking about
it what a
disaster okay well thank you for the
update I appreciate it yes I wish I
could meet you under better conditions
every let's get you some food all right
thank
you
well can I um start off with stuffed
zucchini and then got to go for the lamb
shank as well I saw that and then musaka
Musa please Co and I think that'll be it
for now okay yeah definitely thank you
so
much bring it up come on well obviously
things aren't going right since Chef
Ramsey Ramsey and came out today but I'm
not going to let anyone defeat
me I got it all right
zucchini just [__] do this Jake likes
to just get in and get out fast he knows
better and I know better than to use the
microwave turny to Gordon
Ramsey right now Jake is very lazy it's
pretty messed
up embarrassing
dude stuff zuc Kini is
delightful
screwed what is that stop stop yeah look
at
that it's like two grenades about to
explode my God now it looks like
something out of an alien movie when
zucchini
attack wow that's badly SE
blind no girl no that's disgusting I
could cry what a
joke wow sorry about that
what are they saying St zucchini was
horrible oh [__] it we're
good hated it why try this he hat it
it's
[Music]
too Jake's ability at this moment is
zero he doesn't care anymore I shank
it's coming man I'm doomed completely
lamb shank
now there's a very anemic looking lamp
Shack look at the presentation it's
depressing almost like it's uh been in
the microwave for an hour surely they
wouldn't microwave at them shank a
little bit nervous to how gray the meat
is that is way too salty and and badly
balanced Dustin I mean so salty who
cooked that uh Dustin that's chef Mike
Chef who chef
Mike it's a microwave I thought it was a
third Chef he kind of is he does a lot
of work in the kitchen we use chef Mike
a lot whenever there's lights on in this
restaurant Chef Mike's working he's a
dedicated employee he asked about Chef
Mike he asked who cooked it I mean I
can't lie to him so I told
him he's not happy holy [__]
dude I can't take this
[__] hello hi
I am Kiki Kiki yeah how are you nice to
see you ni is good may I finish my lunch
first and then have a CH Eng no English
no okay I'm sorry Scottish no French no
Spanish German German little bit
okay I don't speak German but it's good
to know thank you thank you what's that
smell is it just me you go outside take
a big deep breath of fresh air come I
know I smell your cologne but smells
good okay wait ready let's do
it yeah why is that no it doesn't smell
to you there no no it just smell you
there I just smell you did somebody die
in here last night no
possible Jes okay is that all right me
haven't tasted the food yet all right
I'd love to meet Dad all right I'll go
get
him what's that smell can you smell
something no no how are you good to see
you same here come say hello and you are
Louis leis the manager are you the
manager yes yeah good to see you same
here Dad yes ma'am Chef Ramsey would
like to meet you me meet you why me I
don't know doesn't make any sense why
would you want to meet you follow me I
am quite nervous about shff Ramsey's
visit and how my dad's self-esteem will
take it because he has have a hard time
taking criticism this is my father Mike
Mike I'm Mike pleasure but the fact is
we need the help and if somebody's
willing to give it to us us we need to
take it I really hope that he can help
that how long you been open 15 years 15
years yeah when was the last time you
changed something in the dining room uh
never wow everything is pretty much as I
bought it 15 years ago and how would you
rate your food 1 to 10 I would wrate my
food in the upper nines wow great I love
that I can't wait to taste it the food
is not the problem here it's either the
atmosphere the Ambiance or the
service here is your regular menu and
here's the specials menu sir do someone
PP on my
menu is that is that I don't know that's
not a Your Own St I don't think so I'm
pretty sure it's probably coffee okay
great thank you if you need anything I'm
at the
front smell hello hello hello hello how
are you me I'll be your server tonight
good to see you can you smell that was
it just me you smell something
right yes H it's like that we' buried
like bodies underneath the carpet yes
it's most defin Ely the carpet stinks
the restaurant is filthy disgusting it's
full of mold it's worse over there
seriously you're in the good
part thank you very
much um steak and sea food and we have
Italian food J what is it fine dining
restaurant we Italian what are we I
don't know wow there is no
identity okay I'll start with Greenie
with shrimp sauce and let's go for
chicken Murphy and then the special menu
the steak Nelly the steak Nelly how
would you like that cooked midr midr
please thank you very much you're very
welcome I want to see where that N9 out
of 10 is hitting it's only that there
yeah I'm
moving Mike I have Chef Ramsay's order
here we go Chef Ramsey will like the
food here anything that I make him he's
going to like
guaranteed look at this
place
disaster Lou chef to that lamb shade
over there on the
wall I don't
know fix it is bugging me how are you
nice to see it's driving me crazy I'm oh
it comes on when it goes up
[Music]
anyway sorry let watch your head
there that's for a chef make it
nice I made it so it's right on the
money
okay Chef thank you you're welcome
greeny with shrimp sauce greeny with
shrimp
sauce oh
dear wow that's gross yeah it's bland
it's just the sauce is BL he's watery
and shrimps and like rubber it's
horrible and you know what I'll have the
uh hot the platter the platter okay and
I'll take the cold platter as well I'd
like to see that I want to see as much
as possible okay anything else I'll have
the masaka egg castle with the beef yeah
with the beef brilliant I think we're
done thank you I'm very excited s fr the
guyy smart and Mikey he needs to see
when the food is not good everything's
not
good calamari appetiz and make it hit
the olive oil and put onions and bell
peppers with the wine you guys do what I
say Mike is a very proud person he does
not take criticism well but CH fr's here
to help he's not here to
compliment nice tables why would you
cover them Dreadful tablecloths noty
hell the deck is
hideous I haven't seen chairs like this
since they're bankr 30 years ago my
grandma's
80th is that a disco ball up there
Saturday Night Fever in fact like
there's two disco balls up there what's
going on in here I was like going back
to
okay that that's a camama okay we
looking to heaven or
hell oh dear and this is our C okay
great thank you enjoy it thank you it's
greasy it looks like I'm having a hell
day right yeah it's not yeah it's not
it's not good
yeah it's terrible oh dear can I take it
away M quickly I
know
D how was itari not good very greasy
people love it yeah it's very greasy
very
popular that's a strange looking
humus seriously look the only way to eat
that is this
St seriously I mean yeah it's ridiculous
Greek dips it looks like six plates of
Greek do [__] that's what it goes in
like imagine what it's going to come out
like Mike the rest and the hom is the
most
important he ate it with his strong I
mean you have to be really idiot to make
the humus
watery this is our H sampler wow okay
Jesus meatballs are cold in the middle f
look like they've been Sat On by a
[__] Greek goddess yeah I know and
the fer paste a lot of fer paste but
hardly anything in them yeah and greasy
very shiny yeah not good and they're
terrible there's no filling in there
thank you thank you that taste of Grease
yeah Taste of
greasy what the [__] is that what is
that this is a mousakas musas that's
with the roasted uh potatoes okay great
thank you thank you I enjoy
it wow
Saka it's drab I mean it's shocking so
bad
Dreadful
Demitri the eggplant is spongy and raw
you having the musaka yeah disgusting
carrots and mush that is an insult to
any Greek aisle listen can you get me
all the chefs in the kitchen out on the
dance I'd like to meet them please of
course okay guys all of the cooks he
want them over there he wants all the
cooks everybody you complain I mean for
laugh s to me it was look good I saw
someone my footage not the way he was
describing the foot oh dear dear oh dear
oh dear that was a disaster I mean I've
just sat down and had the biggest
[__] embarrassment to grease that
I've ever tasted in my entire life to me
it's Chef R's just another customer I
mean as long as he likes my food we're
going to get along just fine a
salad good to go walking out I think
he's going to love the salad it's a
grilled lettuce I mean can't go wrong
grilled salad come
on it is grilled you're still amazed I'm
shocked I've never thought about it but
it's true like wait why are we grilling
lettuce sorry for interrupting just 2
seconds but this is a first for me a
grilled Caesar
salad no but they actually
grilled the
lettuce um could you just show a hand if
anyone else has ever had a grilled
Caesar salad before anybody here ladies
no sorry for interrupting
sorry oh
jeez I always get nervous when a chef
serves me the butts the lettuce when
you've got the but of the lettuce on you
can never clean the lettuce properly and
unfortunately it's not very nice inside
dry chicken the salad looks hideous why
is it so spicy take it everything is
spicy Everything Jesus
thanks grilled Caesar salad coming in
Chef chicken is dry the butt of the
lettuce never should be at the end of
the lettuce okay and why does salad have
to be spicy we're a Mexican American
Cuisine well he's clearly not from
Mexico so first of all Caesar Sal is not
from Europe it's from Mexico I mean I'm
the Mexican here you're not it's
supposed to be
spicy oysters oh the flesh Fri yes
thanks
D are you kidding me that's an oyster
honestly looks like a fossil from
Jurassic
Park wow that is disgusting can you get
me Richard please
[Music]
sorry yes sir sit down okay what was the
last time you sat down and actually ate
off your menu I have not sampled the
entire menu like on a regular basis wow
yeah I want you to close your eyes now
please all right okay I'm just try and
identify that tell me what you taste
there taste a lot of bread lot of bread
H little he here we go again yeah
something all you're right yeah okay
yeah please here please thank you
sh Rich needs water it's about time for
You Know Rich to actually take taste the
food and see what's going on don't choke
now yeah it was it was the spice that
got me at the end yeah the spice they
got you it's the bread that got me how
give that no good on the oysters uh yeah
not good next up is salmon salmon let's
live in
Hope what happened everything is just
way too
spicy Chef Jorge thought that he was
going to impress uh chef ramsy with his
food and he wasn't impressed
I hope that this is definitely like an
eye opener for him so she played us
really hard don't worry bab thank you
okay that looks like the bottom of a
[__] bird cage okay I mean sumon s a
bed of sticky rice with a green curry
bird blond what the [__] is going on in
there it's like the United Nations of
main courses there what's the style it's
a it's I guess it's a little convoluted
isn't it that's one way of putting it
yeah
[Music]
okay I want you to taste this go for the
regu and the
strawberries I mean just the combination
the rice is just hideous the spice is
ridiculous and the strawberries and the
Red Onion Ru yeah I had no idea we had
that many problems with the food to Chef
Ry diece seted it we got a lot of work
to do he here don't we that's the
understatement of the Year hey how are
you bu how are you how you doing good to
see you're running pleasure you're busy
aren't you I have to be somebody's got
to get it done how long you been here oh
3 years who Des this place I feel like
Donal Summer's going to come through the
door that would be M I think that would
be me oh I
absolutely love the decor and dance
party that's me wow excuse
me okay hello darl look at those
beautiful blue eyes I asked my fiance if
I could kiss you fiance he's our manager
the one yeah oh come on sexy right you
get arrested for snatching Hey general
manager come hear you get that beard
over here you didn't tell me that you're
dating the
owner we are EXC we are engaged amazing
and was it Love at First Bite yeah wow
way to a man's heart is a
stum oh man he's a little younger than I
am but he's my sexy chocolate let me sit
down have a quick look through the menu
start ordering thank you thank you for
coming
Gordon I'm going to see as much as I can
okay uh right let's go for uh collar
greens that smothered pork chop sounds
delicious let's go for some mac and
cheese as well please okay the chitlins
and desserts how's the red velvet cake
delicious okay great very wealthy I'm
starving we're going to put your order
in excellent all right guys we have our
order for Chef all right let's do it I
really think that Chef Ramsey is going
to say that the food is phenomenal get
the pork chop put some MK this is not
hot just m
it this is the craziest Decor I've ever
seen wow another record yeah they're all
over so first name is
Eloise
what's oh oh
Jesus what happened was it the fried
chicken or the cornbread what what when
chiens what happened goodness I have no
idea I never seen that
before oh [__] oh my god did somebody
had but the wall it was shocking to find
that it was a hole in the wall with a
record on it I was just like oh my God
like what the hell is that doing there
I've heard about broken records but
Jesus Christ okay let's get out of here
quick I'm afraid to touch any other
[Music]
records all right here you go oh now you
know that is a pretty plate right right
there shell is delusional about how
fabulous her food is I hate the macaroni
and cheese just looks like crap on a
plate this is pork chop the smell the
pork chop thank
[Music]
you that's ni little shot on my
plate it's just
[Music]
dry that's Bland nothing's seasoned
there how's your pork chop the pork chop
is dry the mac and cheese is way up
cooked B mushy you think a soul food
restaurant would Pride itself on cooking
mac and cheese but no it's just all is
that heated in the microwave then no I
think they just put it in the in the
oven to warm for our lunch service thank
you what's wrong he's saying that the
macaroni and cheese is dry and overcook
o he asked me have we warmed it in the
microwave I told him no it just came out
of the oven they may have put it in the
microwave for a minute only for a minute
though everything is cooked to
Perfection there is nothing on that menu
that is not
perfect hello how are you doing today
how are you I'm doing fine welcome to
mich's my name is tsha I'll be your
server this evening it's loveely name he
looks immaculate my goodness
[Music]
me he ain't never seen a beautiful thick
black girl like me so that's what that
was he liked all these curls and stuff
are you that high maintenance or is it
just a special day today it's a special
day today we don't make hardly any money
here so I about to pay this every week
m-m um you've been here how long I've
been here for 2 and a half years 2 and a
half years in your mind what's wrong
what's the biggest issue here management
management wow so what does Natalie
do um
truth what's her role she make sure we
get paid mhm and that's about it
[Music]
right okay now she got issues she lazy I
said it this it is what it is okay
that's done off with smoked chicken
gourmet salad okay beef brisket pork
ribs and what side cornbread mashed
potatoes and the potato salad as well
potato salad we can't do it cuz we don't
have it no potato salad no really yeah
the
kitchen kitchen one they don't like to
peel
potatoes
well it's true okay green beans please
and baked beans obviously black ey peas
okay I didn't hear you say sweet potato
Su yeah okay color greens mac and cheese
please I'll go ahead and get your food
yes please oh thank you and that is the
smoke chicken
wing and when were they smoke this
morning they were smoke this morning
lovely smells enjoy thank
[Music]
you
damn it's try what a shame cuz a sauce
it's lovely but
me it's all
dry that's
disappointing so I'm anxious to know
what you thought yeah do you know what a
bit inside it was
dry was it yeah will you just find out
when they were smoked I will thank take
thank
you I shocked that Chef Ramsey does not
like our smoke wings that just pisses me
off because he's definitely wrong um
thank you what a shame they were trying
the chicken welcome to mine at least
there should be mo why would they try
cuz it's bootleg bootleg mhm they just
don't care thank
you wow is this this morning's bch you
do yesterday's batch this is yesterday's
batch okay Chef I have to e Crow those
are yesterday's Wings damn see I knew
they didn't taste fresh and why they
serving yesterday's wings today
kind I get today's WIS
today I don't know oh anyway just
asking all right are we ready to rock
and
roll a go me salad and all these Sid
okay let's go okay let's go it's
enough oh there yeah lovely thank
you uh God that was quick ma there you
are sir thank you very much you're
welcome that's my uh smoked chicken
gourmet salad
um gross they're rotten
[Music]
tomatoes where's my lovely L I'm right
here I am sorry though but the tomatoes
they got old and sort of yucky and Soggy
I wasn't sharped at all thank you please
have you seen the kitchen they don't
care anyway if the food was that good
back in 1981 how is it today I think
it's better now that's great news yeah I
have a following for 30 years and what I
do I am the best there is but there's
some things that can be changed youthful
22y old like the website uh who else is
running the restaurant my brother uh
Antonio Tony that's encouraging very
encouraging in terms of a proper family
run restaurant I have my wife Tony and
uh my my children let's have a little
catch up with the family shall we okay
yeah are they all here yeah they're all
here to meet bring them out this is my
lovely wife Grace hi nice to meet you
good to see you too where you from Italy
this is your wife yes wow you did well
and this is Dominica the daughter okay
wonderful and this is my sister-in-law
my brother's wife that's my husband
Antonio
Antonio how are you oh very good D
pleasure anony Tony what would you like
to be called I go by Tony Tony okay
great uh let's sit down and let's have a
catch up shall we I'm glad that Chef
Ramsey is here to help help us because
uh this is a family restaurant and we
shouldn't be a split Family Restaurant
first of all I'm here to help and I
can't help unless I know what's with
wrong what's wrong with the restaurant
we had a a phenomenal
leader and the leader was my father he
was in the front him and I were always
on the same page and where's your father
now where is he he's in Italy retired so
no one's actually ever stepped into your
father's shoes well I have but I think
what has happened is no one has any uh
idea what is needed in this
restaurant we're in a position to lose
everything so who runs it now I'm the
I'm the guy in charge right now well on
the way we run it is on Mondays Tuesdays
and Wednesdays I run the place and then
on Thursday nights through Sunday nights
they run the place wow it's crazy how
does a family restaurant not run as a
family they don't get along
because you know belong in this
restaurant is a tra yeah when you have
laziness it's an infection what happens
is when Tony is here and Linda is here
they have no understanding that number
one is the customer no sitting around no
looking at the TV watching TV when
customers come is that true I don't I
don't think it's true T he don't care
about the custom he was seen it and play
the computer I care about this
restaurant the computer here talk with
the computer come on the complaints are
the people feel neglected yeah but
there's also complaints like I don't
want to come there when she's there
customers don't want to come when you're
working what's all that about I don't
know it's I'm just asking listen I'm
she's got people that she kisses ass to
and they love her she's got other people
that she gets blunt in her face and ha
her is it right to just basically go up
to the customer and just say [__] you
get the [__] out of here no I don't say
that I [__] you don't telling me this
bull [__] okay say that CL that's what
you said no I you this is what happened
yeah yeah yeah I did it right I did it
wrong I'm just trying to figure out what
happened I mean I I wasn't here did she
say [__] you did she not say [__] you I
thought she did I didn't hear [__] you
no oh yeah did you he didn't say that
she said that to you you forget what do
you got to forget for you got to be
honest I'm being h just got to help you
or not I'm trying to get him to help I'm
not say the way it is I am no you're not
you're lying I'm not lying you guys are
lying I think she [__] you you think no
she did she did say [__] you you [__]
wrong that's all we are losing the
business
you him no you see this is why we don't
get along 2 years later when I come back
I almost had a heart attack Everything I
seen was dirty so if this is filthy I'm
wor about what the kitchen looks like
kitchen out of control that's a disgrace
disgusting what are you doing they
destroyed everything I worked for in my
life there was no Management in the
restaurant I Chas without
without it's period nothing we owe 1,400
for the meat overdue for the past month
I need my goal to make some money what
are you going to do Michael I don't know
I was going to ask you we got to do
something Michael you tell me what do
you want me to do I need Chef Ramsey to
come in and straighten him out Chef
Ramsey he be my
voice if this doesn't work out I will
have no other choice but to
[Music]
die right
is here we go you think of New Jersey
you think of
Italian hey hello Gordon how are you
doing likewise good to see you too um
first name is Michael Michael good to
see you me to so you are owner owner
okay um what's that thing there that's
uh my old uh television that I watch all
the games on oh you watch the games on
there yes sir seriously yes sir but this
is the main entrance right yes sir wow
is business that flat that you're
watching games and trying to deal with
customers at the same time yes it is
Chef really yes that bad yes sir wow go
outside yes sir and come back in in 10
seconds
[Music]
okay hello table for one sir yeah I'm
busy 2 seconds I'm just going to watch
this go would you mind I'll see myself
uh I'm busy I'm just trying to find the
game it's so important because this is
far more important than running my
business seriously honestly Michael did
you get the message I mean it's just do
you think that's a good impression for
customers Walking In For the First
Time no terrible Chef Ramsey looked at
me in such a way like what is this
rodent doing next to a television in a
restaurant it was just embarrassing oh
my God is that a baby yes I mean they
say that there's never an ugly baby I
think I've just found one but that's not
you is it no sir we have one of the
worst Accords I've ever seen the creepy
baby keeps me up at night I don't know
what my mother was thinking to be honest
with you everything you see every
artwork is my mother right my mother's
actually owner and I was kind of like
the general M tell she got sick
everything she got sick yes and mom's
name is Rose okay Rose and is is your
mother here yes okay can we meet please
please how are you how are you good to
see you
sweet good to see you like seeing you
life nice
St I've been married three times I mean
number four are you feeling better yes
okay and how long have you been back in
the business 2 months so you just come
back now and how long were you out for 2
years I was a vegetable oh really wow
I'm sorry um how long have you had the
the restaurant 14 years in your mind
what's wrong with the restaurant what is
[Music]
it
everything everything okay um let's get
the group together and uh let's have a
little meeting and a catch up and I'd
like to hear from everybody so I can get
my head around this okay yeah can we get
the chefs and uh yeah everybody please
Michael yeah
my I'm everything I got on
him